all right make contact
contact
pittsburgh police
petersburg police come out with your
hands up
what's
come lock him up
i'll keep doing it
let's call sony
put your hands on your
back who else is in the house
keeping on him
[Music]
that is negative
glad you could join the party
air guns
four two one eight four two one eight
four
came out of the house
get the fuck off my property this that
in the third baldy's fist up come down
to step so he's gonna do something
we got done
taser worked just great too by the way
talking like does he have like uh he's
got some kind of metal thing going on
when this came out cuba said that
i guess they were dealing with something
but he does
just so you can report back i have
effectively neutralized
i was on the road
he came out the uh came out the door
raising hell screaming at me and jackson
okay
i said hey man you know just
he come down him steps baldi's fist
though so i hit him with the taser is
this the same call that came up with
that lady said he was mentally he had a
pipe in his hand or something like that
yeah i got the phone call i came out
okay and i got but both of them are soft
i got them
now the pipes in the house i didn't need
to get that okay but i couldn't tell
about the same guy or not because he
came out the first time when i saw him
he was wearing underwear and a durag
so i want to clear the house and i saw
the guns laying there the aerosol
he's got a mental issue he's going to be
tv
okay
well please report back so they wouldn't
think i was insubordinate
no sarcasm
all right all right i figured this was
the same call
yeah but we checked all down here before
he must have just dipped out before we
got here
my family so i'm going to talk to him
about you get you his name and
information sure sharp like a knife
sharp like a knife
i mean i'm stationed
okay
all right jax when the crews can get
here to get him checked out and have the
tds
i hit you with the taser and i'm doing
it
i appreciate that where you living okay
i live in your nightmares
better men than you tried to kill me son
that's the best i can tell you
better than you tried to kill me
so i had to get the prongs out
taking down the tdoing okay papers table
cco okay uh you saw the way it was that
came out agitated one of them
put your pants
um
i don't know if he's going to take him
better yeah
the best i can tell you
oh i got him in the neck with a taser oh
nice bleeder too
yeah the crew's got to come checking out
again because i got him right the neck
of one of his prongs that's fun he looks
fine
yeah it's got a little blood coming out
of him wait uh jackson's gonna do a
people's eco on him
he's just talking gibberish
there's no doubt i'll just put the bb
guns into a property okay i didn't take
the fight and it's just a fight